the central pillar of the Advent
movement was the Declaration until
2300 days then shall the sanctuary be
cleansed this first Daniel 8 14 is the
foundation stone of our theology it is
the investigative judgment text it is
absolutely indispensable To What We
Believe
that God is doing and will do
in the Jewish economy the Jewish system
God gave them seven annual Feasts
beginning with the Passover ending with
a feast of uh Tabernacles the Passover
was the first Feast it was celebrated on
the 15th day of the seven on the 14th
day of the first month announced or the
month Nissan it was the month in which
the Israelites came out of captivity
from Egypt and so that month Nissan or
abib on the 14th day was when the
Passover was celebrated and the very
last
ceremony was the Feast of Tabernacles
representing the celebration in the new
world when that will take place now of
the seven feasts and if I may go through
all seven the first one was Passover
which is represented by the sacrifice of
Christ Paul said in First Corinthians 5
7 Christ Our Passover is crucified for
us the second was the Feast of 11 bread
which ran for seven days and it began
the day right after the Passover the
third was the Feast of um first fruits
the the fourth was the Feast of Weeks
which is called in the New Testament
Pentecost because Pentium means a 50
Pentecost 50th day I believe those first
four occurred in the spring the next
three were the Feast of Trumpets on the
first day of the seventh month the month
of tishary the sixth Feast was the day
of atonement on the 10th day also of
teshire and the last one was on the 15th
day and it ran for about seven days the
Feast of Tabernacles of these seven
feasts listen carefully the most solemn
the most sacred day was the day of
eternal that was the only day on which
the high priest went into the most holy
place on no other feast day did he enter
the most holy Place only on the day of
atonement that he went into that most
holy place it was on that day that the
curtain was changed and the new one was
installed representing the beginning of
a brand new religious year it was during
that Feast that symbolically sin was
removed from the camp forever in the
person of a goat that was taken away by
a strong man taken away so that it would
never come back these were all symbols
but they teach us powerful lessons about
the gospel in all his phases and I'm
saying all of that to say of the seven
feasts the most important the most solid
and the one that was clearly a day of
judgment was the day of atonement the
sixth of the seven feasts and it
occurred on the 10th day of the seventh
month or the month tertiary
and so it was a day of judgment when God
cleansed the century from the sins of
his people and all the church were
required to gather around the sanctuary
in worship it was a day of fasting it
was a day of searching oneself it was a
day of avoiding work
all of that took place on that day and a
day of worship it was a day of judgment
and anyone found with sin on that day
was cut off from among the people it was
solemn to the point if I may use the
word frightening now that was symbolic
back then but the anti-typical the
actual fulfillment or beginning of this
Feast was October 22 1844 that's when
the day of atonement began in heaven the
same way of the Passover which was
celebrated on the 14th day of the first
month that found its fulfillment in the
sacrifice of Jesus Christ the Feast of
Weeks it found this fulfillment in the
day of Pentecost and so each Feast must
move from symbolic to actual fulfillment
and with regard to the day of atonement
that actual fulfillment began if one
counts carefully October 22
1844 which corresponds to the 10th day
of the seventh month so I've tried to
answer the question what is the day of
atonement it is the day of judgment it
is a day of Investigation it is a day of
searching the records to see who should
who really belongs to God and who does
not and who will receive the final
reward which is a life with God or the
final punishment which is uh destruction
not burning forever in hell as some
churches that is my long response to
your question what is the it is the
spinal cord
of our teachings it is right in the
middle of the Three Angels messages
Revelation 14 6 and 7 and I saw another
Angels fly in the midst of Heaven having
the Everlasting gospel to preach unto
them that dwell on the earth and to
Every Nation Kindred tongue and people
saying that Allah's voice fear God and
give glory to him for the hour of his
judgment is come but it is also a time
for the universe to see how just God has
always been because
unfallen people such as us on the earth
angels in heaven those on unfallen
worlds perfect though they are do not
understand everything they had questions
about the way God dealt with sin the way
God therefore Satan and in this
investigative judgment or as the
scholars call it pre-advert judgment
They will receive a revelation of the
absolute justice of God of the love of
God and that all that God did from the
time sin occurred until this present
moment has been right and just and
actually
Satan will be the last person to declare
that yes God was right every knee shall
bow including Satan every tongue shall
confess ultimately that Jesus Christ is
Lord but the verse Ends by saying to the
glory of God the Father the Vindication
of the Father the clearing of his name
and part of that of that is done through
the faithful lies of his people all of
that is a partial response to the
question what is the investigate is
absolutely and by the way let me say
this
almost every Bible scholar or Bible
teacher who has left the Seventh-day
Adventist Church has attacked that
teaching it is this the teaching above
all others that no other Christian
Church preaches
you know the other churches that preach
baptism by immersion other churches talk
about excuse me other churches believe
in the Trinity they believe in the
Divinity of Christ
only seven of the Adventists
preach and Proclaim the investigative
judgment
excuse me and so the enemy wants to
block that out so that we're like
anybody else
that's why the most ferocious attacks
are directed against this teaching the
teaching of the investigative judgment
or as our Bible scholars call it the
pre-advert Judgment the fact that
something is going on in heaven now and
destinies are being decided while people
are running and doing their business on
this Earth something solemn
solemn is going on in heaven it began
with the days of Adam and it will move
on to the living
all right I pause doctor your turn no
powerful powerful Elder skeet and it's
so interesting you brought up that last
point that a lot of persons that leave
The Seventh-Day Adventist Church either
leave because of this Doctrine or women
really attack this doctrine that was
actually uh you know just searching up
on YouTube investigative judgment SDA
and I saw former Adventists that you
know came up and they said this Doctrine
is the reason I left the Seventh-day
Adventist Church so this investigative
judgment is found nowhere in the Bible
I mean type in anti-type it's a
fulfillment but perhaps that is a
question Elder skeet how did this phrase
investigative judgment arise now the
phrase is not in the Bible investigated
it does not need to be in the Bible the
concept is on the Bible the reality is
in the Bible now this concept of of this
principle of judgment before punishment
goes all the way back to the Garden of
Eden in Genesis chapter 3 from verse 9
the Bible says unto the Lord God called
unto Adam and said unto him where is
thou God came down God knew what had
happened but God came down to interact
with Adam to examine what had happened
in a way that Adam could understand
before he issued his punishment his
penalty to the snake to the woman and to
Adam he investigated first when Cain
kill Abel God came to Canada what have
you done where is Abel that took place
first then God told him Cain he'll be a
vagabond in the Earth when the flood was
before the flood was sent God used Noah
God saw that the wickedness of man was
great in the earth Genesis 6 verse 5 and
that every imagination of the thoughts
of his heart was only evil God saw he
examined he assessed and he concluded
something needs to be done but daughter
is Mercy gave them 120 years to repent
before God sent Solomon God destroyed
the uh the Tower of Babel the Bible says
God said I will God came down to see the
seat in the tower which the children of
man building uh Genesis 11 verse 5 when
God came down to talk to Abraham
regarding Sovereign Gomorrah God said
because the Cry of son was very great
and because the sin is Grievous I will
go down now and see whether they've done
all together according unto the Cry of
it which is common to me and if not I
will know God because we're limited God
functions in a way we can understand so
God says I will go and see for myself
and God saw and then God punished God
examines then he punishes so the concept
of an investigation is thoroughly
thoroughly biblical God gave the Jews
490 years to do what they should have
done beginning at 455 ending in 80 34.
he all of that Christ came to the Earth
personally and saw the behavior of his
beloved people before punishment was
proclaimed as a nation as individuals
any one of them could come to God as a
favorite Nation he ended 1834 but it
ended only after God has assessed have
examined and investigated and decided
this needs to stop I will move to the
Gentiles and to spiritual Jews
investigation in God's system precedes
the execution of punishment
so while the expression investigative
judgment is not in the Bible it is a
Biblical concept A seriously biblical
concept and I and my heart breaks for
those who say they left because of this
teaching because they did not understand
it they did not understand the sanctuary
Services they have not understood so
that they could move from symbolic to
anti-typical they did not understand
but we know some who left will come back
so we hope they'll come back
that was that question touched on it in
your answer to the first question it is
how is the investigative judgment
connected with the sanctuary message
well it's uh all the activities took
place around the sanctuary on the day of
autonomous the tenth day of the month uh
tertiary the seventh month of the
religious year of the Hebrews everything
you see the sanctuary was the center of
Hebrew life in the wilderness and indeed
in the after the Wilderness wanderings
there were three feasts where all men
were required to come to Jerusalem but
in the world of this this century was
the center of their life that's where
they brought they sacrificed so whether
it was the Passover represented by the
animal that was killed on the 14th day
of the first month or whatever it was
the first fruits everything happened at
the sanctuary
the devil tournament included the most
holy place and so everything as I said
earlier is centered in the century
everything now centers in the Heavenly
Sanctuary because the Earthly Sanctuary
merely represented it was built based on
a pattern that Moses was given we read
that Nexus uh the last chapter and we
read out in Hebrews chapter 8 and
chapter nine and so the the most holy
place is now the focus of activity in
heaven the most holy place where of
course the Throne of God is found and
where the law of God is found by the way
because the reason for All This calamity
is simply the law of God was violated
that's why the law was in the most holy
place not the outer Court where the
altar was for sacrifice not the holy
place but the Candlestick was the shoe
bed was the alt of incense one it was in
the most holy because the problem is and
was the fire nation of God's love and
that law had a price had to be paid of
course Jesus Paid that and those who
accept Christ his payment covers us so
everything centers in the most holy
place right now that has been the case
since 1844 October 22.
amen eldest key I know the holy spirit
is moving because my next question was
when did the investigative judgment
begin October 22 1844 of course that
takes time to go into it but it can be
studied reasonably intelligently and you
will conclude clearly that that is when
based on the symbolic we come to an
accurate uh conclusion regarding when
the anti-typical began October 22 1844
which corresponds to the 10th day of the
seventh month after 2 300 days Daniel 8
14 the the the part of the vision Daniel
could not understand and God said
Gabriel to help him understand because
it was so important and no wonder it's
the one part of the vision or all that
God gave to Daniel that caused people to
leave and cause people to question uh
our Common Sense approach to the
inerrancy of scripture this this
investigative judgment teaching it was
so critical God commanded Gabriel make
this man to understand the vision the
one part Daniel could not clearly get he
fainted at the end of uh uh General
chapter eight he wanted to understand
about this cleansing of the sanctuary we
now have the resources to understand and
we disdain it we just then something
Daniel yearn to understand it's it's
really certain astonishing
so October 22 1844 was when the typical
day of atonement began and it has been
going on since then and we began with
the dead it will move to the living we
have no precise date for when it will
move to the living
but it will get to that point but we
have no precise date
seeing that
get in touch when it's not unfounded it
wasn't concocted in the mind of
Adventist Pioneers that was revealed to
them as they had an understanding of the
sanctuary and that's actually what
unlocked the key to birth The
Seventh-Day Adventist movement actually
the only church on Earth really I hate
to make a swimming statement that
studies the sanctuary is The Seventh-Day
Adventist Church
you will not hear another Pulpit
proclaiming the century message it is
really not only the investigative
judgment but in a certain sense the
sanctuary teaching as a whole is
peculiar to The Seventh-Day Adventist
Church even though it's available to
everyone in the word of God
indeed indeed powerful powerful
statement Elder skeet
um
so now that we know what the
investigative judgment is we know when
it began why we have it who is actually
being judged in this time period all
right good question let me tell you
exactly who then try to uh support that
biblically
all those who've ever confessed a
relationship with Christ right now are
being judged the ones who you see in the
sanctuary
the priests atoned for sins that were
confessed are you following me sins that
were confessed and people confess sins
because they recognize God they have
some relationship with God so they
confessing the sins that were confessed
are the sins that were atorned for and
so the Judgment deals with those who
have at some point declared themselves
to have a relationship with God but
since Jesus said the wheat and tears
will grow together something has to be
done to separate the tomb the sheep and
the ghost may be into some heard
something has to be done to separate the
two when the fishermen cast out his neck
in Matthew 13 he brought in all kinds of
fish something had to be done to
separate the fish the good one from the
undesirable ones and so those being
judged are those who may be considered
to be members of the household of God
first Peter 4 17 judgment must begin at
the house of God and so the righteous
dead or those who died having proclaimed
some connection with Christ with God
they are being judged as I said earlier
the judgment will move to the living who
have professed a relationship with God
not all people who profess to know God
are faithful to God second Timothy
chapter 4 verse 9 do that diligence to
come shortly unto me for Demas have
forsaken me having loved this present
world the mass left Christ Judas
betrayed Christ and so some begin with
Christ and leave him and the Book of
Life has these names and some names will
be taken out of that book based on their
relationship with God you said you love
God you believed in him let us examine
your life and based on the lies uh
Conformity with God's law that name is
kept or removed this is really quite
simple despite the fact that it's
frightening and so anyone who at some
point has claimed a relationship with
God
are the ones being judged
now there's another judgment I should
say that will occur during the
millennium
that will be the Judgment of the wicked
because the wicked had nothing to do
with God so no relationship at all no
need to judge him in the investigative
judgment these things never went up
during the Thousand Years the Millennium
as we call it even though Millennium is
not in the Bible but a thousand years is
certainly there
then the wicked will be judged that's
another phase of the Judgment this phase
is the one that takes in those who
profess some kind of relationship with
God that is why judgment begins at the
house of God
and each person is judged individually
you know one is taking so long
you're not judges families each one
appears before God individually when I
say appear by virtue of your life's
record not you personally showing up
from the dead in Heaven know your life's
record that's how you appear
Paul writes right secret let me
recommend a book let me recommend the
book for those listening whether you
land for this or not get the book 1844
Made Simple
and read it
1844 if another life of this find an
Adventist bookstore get the book 1844
Made Simple read it and then reread it
prayerfully
amen amen thank you all the skeet so
once again we're just we're seeing this
Motif in order for us to understand
what's happening right now in terms of
the investigative judgment we look to
the pattern of the sanctuary in the Old
Testament he said all the skeet only
those sins that were confessed that were
transferred to the sanctuary those uh
those are the only sins that the high
priest could atone for in that same way
only people that have professed to have
a belief in Jesus
are being investigated
go to John chapter five let me show you
my dear sister and all our viewers
something that Jesus said John chapter 5
yes
we read from verse 45 of John chapter 5.
this is Christ speaking to the Jews
do not think that I will accuse you to
the father there is one that accuseth
you even even Moses when he says Moses
he does not mean Moses is a person he
means the writings of Moses keep reading
for had ye believed Moses he would have
believed me wait a minute which means
that understanding the Old Testament is
indispensable to understanding the new
Moses represents the old Christ clearly
is the new but Christ represents both
old and new but Jesus in his human
existence the new Jesus tells us if you
had believed Moses you would have
believed me and the Heart and Soul of
the writings of Moses really was
the sanctuary activities let them make
me a sign that I might dwell among them
we have to understand that section of
Moses is writings keep reading
for he wrote of me but if you believe it
falls again yes every aspect of the
sanctuary pointed to Jesus except the
scapegoat that was sent away that does
not represent Christ but everything in
the sanctuary service pointed to Jesus
Christ and so Jesus is right when he
said he wrote of me finish that section
now
but if he believed not his writings
how shall ye believe my words absolutely
and the sanctuary service
is the heart of the writings of Moses
the Old Testament I would say
the sanctuary
you do not believe that you cannot
understand Christ's Ministry you just
cannot
Christ himself respected that system
until he died and they passed away
but it must still be studied to be
understood
all right sorry for the interruption Dr
Denisha no no Elder ski that is a
beautiful passage that you that you uh
had us read there and you know sometimes
we forget that this work of
investigative judgment is as the crisis
mediatorial work that he's doing on our
perhaps he's literally fighting for us
to be saved the question is are we
aligning our motives our thoughts and
our lifestyle so that when we are
presented before the father Jesus can
all right so we are going to transition
I'm going to bring on my dear sister
Jasmine Bowen she's actually our ay
leader at my church and she really
asking the next three questions what's
the name
Jasmine hello Jasmine how are you hi I'm
good and you I'm fine do you love Jesus
sister Jasmine I sure do man the case is
closed all right
so the next question is what is the
standard of judgment
what is the standard of judgment oh good
question the standard of judgment is the
righteousness of Jesus Christ
that's the standard
at every level of human history since
the fall the standard has been the
righteousness of Jesus Christ
now that righteousness is expressed in
the law
you understand it's expressed in the law
there is no difference between the law
and the righteousness of Jesus Christ
the Bible tells us let us hear the
conclusion of the whole matter fear God
and keep his Commandments for this is
the whole duty of man for God shall
bring every work into judgment and
what's the Judgment standard the law of
God what does James say James 2 verse 12
so speaky and so do as there shall be
judged by the law of Liberty this law of
God is the standard because the law
expresses the very righteousness of
Christ righteousness of God so the
standard by this this and all those
listening is the righteousness of Jesus
Christ now listen to Romans 8 from verse
one there's therefore now no
condemnation to them which are in Christ
Jesus who walk not after the flesh but
after the spirit for the law of the
spirit of love in Christ Jesus had the
law of the spirit of life in Christ
Jesus have made me free from the law of
sin and death for what the law could not
do in that it was weak through the flesh
God sending his own son in the likeness
of sinful flesh and for sin condemn sin
in the flesh now listen carefully that
the righteousness of the law might be
fulfilled in us
who walked but after the flesh but after
the spirit of Christ came to demonstrate
the righteousness of the law which is
the righteousness of God can be
expressed in US it does not make us God
it makes us Godly it makes us god-like
the same way the Bible is a combination
of human and divine Jesus was a
combination of human and divine we as
humans must have the divine within us as
a sustaining power the standard by this
sister is the righteousness of Christ
that's imputed to us when we acknowledge
Christ as our savior and we acknowledge
our helplessness and we accept him
that's the righteousness that's imputed
to us
and that's the righteousness that's
imparted to us that sustains Us in that
justified condition
didn't mean to go that far all right no
it's okay
so the next question is and what is
being compared to the standard
what is being compared to the standard
yes your life and mine
it is the standard The Ten Commandments
now our lives are brought next to that
standard to see if we are in harmony
or in harmony with the righteousness of
Christ the law of God our lives are
compared to the law of God
Deuteronomy chapter 6 verse 25 and it
shall be our righteousness if we observe
to know all these Commandments before
the Lord Our God as he has commanded us
the law of God is the standard our lives
are brought into comparison to determine
whether we're in harmony with God's law
or out of Harmony because the only way
to be right with God is to be right with
his law
let me say that again
I'll say differently you cannot be right
with God and out of harmony with his law
he or she who is right with God Is Right
with God the person is right with the
law
so our lives are compared to the law of
God
you see the punishment of the Bible are
for the result of the violation of the
law
if someone committed murder the person
had to be killed in the Old Testament
why because the life the action violated
the law the life is compared to the law
and if the Life is In Harmony of the law
it means it is in harmony with God you
cannot separate God from his law
that's why his throne is built on Law
and he sits there yes your question to
what is what is compared to the law the
lives of those in judgments
Romans chapter 3 verse 23 for all have
sinned started to say Jasmine and become
short of the glory of God how do we come
short of the glory we sin what is sin
transgression of the law and so our
lives compared to this standard which is
God's character in code form okay go
ahead
amen it's so funny that you refer to
romance because that's what the next
question is into so our next question is
Romans 3 26 says of God's being just and
the justifiers which believeth in Jesus
yes so what does this mean well the
question is how can God
justify a sinner and God still remain
just himself in other words it's wrong
for God to justify a sinner that's what
some people would say how can a sinner
be considered just how can God do that
God is disrespecting his law God is
disrespecting his personal righteousness
but through Jesus Christ and his
sacrifice an arrangement only the
godhead could have come up with by the
way it was the only way we could have
been saved God had no other Alternatives
through the sacrifice of Christ The
Gospel is the means whereby God can
justify a sinner and God remain just
that thou am I declare when thou speak
now they're without judges
um Psalm 51 verse 4.
the gospel allows God to justify a
sinner and still satisfy the demands of
the law and so God remains just he has
not violated his law and he saved
someone how is that possible through
Jesus Christ
who is the just the the righteousness
the living righteousness whose life is
the living law what the law required
Jesus provided the punishment the law
required Jesus he provided both
and that covers the person who comes to
God and God's justice is untouched God
remains a just God through the Avenue of
the Gospel the sacrifice of Jesus Christ
this is what we'll study for all
eternity it is remarkable we'll never
exhaust it but we must try to understand
it as much as our limited mind will
allow us
when God Saves someone God says just the
Lord satisfied Jesus is happy
mm-hmm amen so now that leads into our
well my final question
what should we be doing now to ensure
that judgment is in our favor get right
with God
as simple as it get right what do I mean
by that give your life to God
every day
because the person whose life is in the
hands of God cannot be lost are you
following me cannot be lost there are
people who terrified by the Judgment the
judgment is an opportunity for God to
demonstrate his righteousness
demonstrate his justice but demonstrate
also that his righteous law was kept by
human beings through the power of Christ
the judgment is a time for God to lift
us up as trophies and show the world
show the Universe show Satan he was
wrong in his original charge that God's
law could not be kept how should we
prepare by being faithful to Jesus
Christ day by day Moment by moment Luke
16 verse 10 he that is faithful in that
which is least is faithful also and much
we're Faithful Little Things We obey God
deserves age of space 324 paragraph one
we may live off many have bad habits for
a while we may part company with Satan
but without a vital connection with God
through surrender ourselves to him
Moment by moment which help you overcome
without the personal acquaintance and a
continual communion we at the mercy of
the enemy and shall do his billing in
the end it is constant constant contact
with God let me express it this way
when God made him he made him Genesis 2
verse 7 and the Lord God formed man of
the Dust of the ground breathe into his
nostrils the Breath of Life Man became
an event Soul so we have dust of the
ground we have breath one from the earth
one from above now
God gave adam the breath of life but not
in one huge breath and he never had to
Breathe Again God made Adam inside he
had to keep breathing Moment by but he
did not have to keep adding dirt are you
following me he did not have to keep
adding dirt to Adam but he had to keep
that breath going every moment we have
to breathe Spirit spiritually it reminds
us every moment I am dependent upon God
every woman I I I I I Surrender myself
to God steps to Christ page 48 paragraph
one
through through constant surrender to
Christ we are unable to live the new
life even the life of Faith steps Christ
Spirit 48 paragraph one through
constant surrender which means there
must be a Consciousness with which we
live I am it's not by Autumn it's not by
automatic pilot it must be conscious
intentional deliberate I'm a Child of
God in this scenario that scenario am I
representing God am I in the word am I
praying I need to stay in Christ because
the only one who can take me from Christ
is not Satan but me
and so the preparation of my sister get
into Christ because anyone outside of
Christ will not survive the judgment
anyone in Christ whose life I don't say
anyone who's uh reached a Perfection of
Christ I said anyone in Christ
cannot be lost
that's the preparation and that requires
constant prayer and the word of God
because it is through the word that
Christ abides in his followers desires
variously 677 paragraph one it is
through the word because the word is
spirit filled the word that I speak unto
you they are Spirit their life when you
have the word not just as a a principle
as a a poem that you memorize as an
active living empowering principle
you've got the Holy Spirit
and you cannot be lost when Christ
dwells in you through his word
amen
thank you so very much but I have a
question um yes so you heard that I was
a writing leader for my church so
how can we as a collective start the
young people on their first step what is
our first action to do get them into the
word of God
show them the love of God for them
personally at their tender age show them
from scripture the love of God for them
it may look hopeless at first if you
continue you will begin to see a change
because the word of God is like a
radiation you expose yourself to it and
something happens to you at the cellular
level give them the word of God
that word will change them I always say
if young people would study the word of
God they would call it the most
interesting book in the world not Harry
Potter the Bible give them the word get
them into the word
and you'll see a miraculous change not
at all but in some amen all who knows
yeah right who knows hey Ben that is all
for my portion of the questions I will
now turn it back over to Denisha thank
you God bless you Jasmine God bless you
thank you
amen thank you so very much sister
Jasmine for ants asking those questions
and I'll disquiet thank you for those
passionate answers
[Music]
thank you so much
more questions two more what are they
how will God deal with sins of ignorance
all right let's pray Father in Heaven as
we continue speaks through all of us I
pray in Jesus name amen
a sin of ignorance is a sin that's
described this way I had no knowledge I
had no way of knowing
last day event space 217 paragraph five
Last Day Events page 217 paragraph five
none will be condemned for not heeding
light and knowledge that he did not have
and he could not obtain let me say it
again none will be condemned for not
heeding like the knowledge that he did
not have and he could not or they could
not obtain
you didn't know there was no way of
knowing that is genuine ignorance John
15 22 if I had not come and spoken unto
them they had not had sin where there is
no knowledge there is no sin that's
charged to your account there is sin but
it is not charged to the person this is
the mercy of God that is why the Bible
begins with God giving Adam information
now he tells Adam in the light of this
information make your choice if you eat
this tree you're dead you leave that
tree alone you live so God gave him
information Adam's sin was not a sin of
ignorance it was sin in the light of
knowledge when someone does not know two
elements must be present I did not know
I had no way of knowing that is
ignorance in God's eyes God overlooks
that and the person is not condemned for
a genuinely ignorant sin the sin is
still a sin but in his mind see God does
not charge that to the person that's how
God deals all those things of course
have to be dealt with Christ by Christ
dealt with by Jesus Christ
because he's the one who carries the
sins of the world
in the times of ignorance God rated
Romans Romans sorry acts 17 verse 31.
amen amen
we live in an age we live in an age
very few people can say I had no way of
knowing in second Peter chapter 3 verse
5 the Bible says for this they willingly
are ignorant of they are people who say
don't tell me that is not ignorance I
don't want to hear don't tell me that is
not ignorance that is self-destruction
that is suicidal Behavior
there is no value in ignorance
regarding God's not God's law because
knowledge is life this is life eternal
that they might Know Thee
knowledge of God is life ignorance has
no benefits all right now to the Nisha
go ahead amen amen thank you I want to
share a quote here from the
investigative judgment in the writings
of Ellen White and ten she says among
the Heathen are those who worship God
ignorantly
those to whom the light is never brought
by human instrumentality yet they will
not perish right though ignorance of the
written law of God they have heard his
voice speaking to them in nature and
have done the things that the law
required read Romans 1 20 in relation to
that read Romans 1 20.
yes
it's a very powerful verse
for the invisible things of him from the
creation of the world are clearly seen
being understood by the things that are
made even his eternal power and godhead
they are without excuse amen someone who
honestly examines nature must honestly
conclude there is a God
there are clearly expressed the Bible
says yet with no direct knowledge of God
the the invisible things of God from the
creation of the world are clearly seen
being understood by the things that are
made that is why the heavens declare the
glory of God Psalm 91 the whole earth is
full of his glory Isaiah 6 3 the glory
of God is this character very few people
can say I had absolutely no insight into
the fact there's a higher being very few
people can say that
um you may not have read a Bible
but God made nature in such a way as to
impress upon the observe of the fact
that there is a creator
and so yes some hidden people will be
there while some church leaders won't
hmm
words for the wise
[Music]
all right Elder Skeets so we have our
last question and after what's that oh
well it is how does the parable of the
five wise and five foolish versions
explain or we can say expound on the
investigative judgment well it the
investigative judgment is not the focus
of that health
the parable that deals with
investigative judgment is a parable of
Matthew 22 from verse 1 to 14. we're the
king send out three invitations the
first was rejected referring to Christ
coming to the Jews the second was
rejected the apostles preaching after
Christ died and the third being the
message of the Gentiles and of course
the king came in in verse 11 of Matthew
22 to see the guests because he made a
marriage for his son verse 1 of Matthew
22. he made a marriage and set the
invited people to come they never came
finally those from the highways and
hedges the rest of the world outside the
Jewish Nation they came
and the King came in to see the guests
he came in before the sun could enter
this is the investigative judgment you
say before there's this uh weddings
wedding reception
you say what's going on now is the
wedding the marriage Christ through this
investigation is determining who his
bride is exactly who when he comes back
there'll be the reception the wedding
reception so now the king comes in in
Matthew 22 11 to see the yes he finds a
man there without a wedding garment he's
thrown into out of Darkness he asked the
man friend how Kim is thou in heaven not
having a garment the Bible says he was
speechless he had no excuse everyone
lost will have no excuse
and so in Matthew 22 we see a very
clearly the investigative judgment being
taught not so much the the parable of
the the wise and foolish version deal
with the condition of the church just
before Jesus Christ comes
I'm not saying it is absolutely
separated but the investigative judgment
is not its focus the parable of Matthew
22 1-14 is the focus the investigative
judgment there is is stressed in verses
11 through 14.
foolish virgins because we fall into one
or other of those two groups okay indeed
indeed and it also tells us for example
that you know the Judgment that's taking
place is happening within the house of
God because within the house of God yes
they were all versions but not all the
lies that's right that's right that's
right so what is the state of our lamps
do we have extra oil and that all is the
holy spirit yes yes so all this kid we
have some open form questions what are
they
someone has raised his hand well here on
the zoom so I will allow murari is hard
to unmute and you can ask your questions
we're taking questions on this topic
amen okay all right okay don't take me
the other direction on this topic okay
all right brother marari on the topic
and the topic I was just asking if
Christ died the second death
well that's the penalty for sin
the second death is the definition
there's no return yet Christ came back
that's the penalty for sin he paid the
price for our sin the second death is
the penalty for sale
but does he died
yes he did
he himself said he was dead Revelation 1
verse 18.
if Christ didn't die the second half
none of us should be saved we have to
pay the penalty for ourselves
the second that's why the Bible says
blessed are they that have take part in
the First Resurrection on such the
second death have no power
the penalty for our sin is paid by
Christ the penalty for sin is the second
death from which there's no return
Christ pay that
how he came back we have to ask him when
we see him but he paid it that's why
those who have faith in Christ can be
saved and despair the penalty of sin
which is the second death total
Annihilation no return
and one more question
I heard that you said um
the sin of ignorance do we know in this
time
came and lived that perfect life and and
we are receiving more greater light more
like do we have no
have no excuse
for not to be saved my brother very few
people today have an excuse because the
availability of knowledge is all over
the opportunities to learn are available
to most people I would say and so very
few people really today can say to God I
didn't know I had no way of knowing you
know as I travel around the world
Wherever I Go people may not have a
house may not have a car or shoes or
they have a phone with internet I don't
know how that works but people have
opportunities to learn the basics of
Salvation very few people in this modern
day will be able to tell God I genuinely
did not know because they must answer
two questions from God one
did you not know did you have an
opportunity to know were opportunities
available to you and the answer will be
yes but I didn't use them so my brother
very few people in this Modern Age can
say they have my excuse and as we said
earlier nature argues powerfully for the
presence of God
okay thank you you're welcome God bless
you
amen amen thank you thank you for your
questions brother marari and thank you
for those answers where's brother Mariah
from
that that's a good question let me okay
that's right he did he did sound
Jamaican but okay yeah I am from Jamaica
blessed Jamaica God bless Jamaica I'm
living in New York though God bless New
York too
all right thanks God bless you my
handsome brother
amen amen thank you thank you all the
skeet so we actually have two questions
here one from Sean Williams and one from
Sister Janella Peters are they connected
they are connected they they actually
submitted these specifically for this uh
I'll take one so why does Jesus make an
investigative judgment when he knows the
end from the beginning but we don't know
the end for the beginning you understand
we don't know the end from the beginning
Jesus was the one who came down to the
God let me pray again fathers I continue
to talk to your lovely people speak
through me their God in Jesus name I
pray amen it was Jesus Christ who knew
everything who came down to the Garden
of Eden to talk to Adam and Eve what did
you do what happened talk to me says God
you know the Bible says come now let us
reason together the reasoning is not for
God's benefit it is for our benefit
because our minds are limited it was
Jesus Christ who came to him and said
where's evil what did you do it was
Jesus Christ who came down to take a
look at those who built the Tower of
Babel it was Jesus Christ who came down
and spoke to Abraham about Sovereign
Gomorrah it was always Jesus
and so John 2 25 tells us Jesus knows
what is in us but we don't know
and so the just angels in heaven don't
understand everything those who live in
unfallen Worlds don't understand
everything the Fallen Angels don't
understand everything they have to
understand so that they may say without
one exception chart God was always right
and so God functions in a way at a level
that finite beings might understand as
much as they can the Justice of the
actions that he takes the righteousness
of his actions they need to understand
so that every tongue will finally
confess that Jesus Christ is Lord to the
glory of God the father let me say again
the perfect angels don't fully
understand the Fallen Angels don't fully
understand the unfallen worlds don't
fully understand we don't fully
understand God has to convince us
that he was always right so he has the
function of the level that we can
understand yes Jesus knows everything
but we don't that's why he does what he
does with regard to the investigative
judgment
amen amen now it'll Escape The Time Is
Now 2 59 p.m yes
I don't want to infringe on your time so
but there's one other question I'll take
it
all right so I see a couple of hands are
raised and I don't put them down put
them down
oh my well you know someone
um
hmm all right I'll take sister janella's
question since I submitted it first she
asks what are some examples in the Old
Testament where the descendants of
Abraham and or children of Israel go
through the investigative judgment and
what are some new testament parallels
well Lots whether the the sentence with
Abraham or not as I said go back to the
Garden of Eden and you see an
investigative judgment
you come to Genesis 18 you see an
investigative judgment regarding Sodom
and Gomorrah you even go to Genesis 11
where God came down to see what the
Builders of people were doing he
investigated the fact that God gave the
Jews for the 90 years may he
investigated their behavior and realized
they had come short he gave them a final
probation and so investigation has been
going on since man fell God always
investigates before he pronounces
judgment from Genesis to Revelation even
though you may not find a precise
example this is the way God sanctions
before the Jewish church was abandoned
by Christ as uh favorite people he came
and personally interacted with them as a
human being he saw their behavior that
was investigation of a certain sort and
so old and new God doesn't change
he investigates before he punishes not
free he's sick but for the sake of the
person to be punished or blessed that
the person may say that God Is Right
God Jesus gave Judas opportunities to
turn around
he didn't Christ clearly examined his
behavior that's why Christ was saying
John 6 17 have I not chosen you 12 one
of you as a devil Christ have assessed
his behavior gave him opportunities to
turn around he never did
keep this principle in mind God does not
execute judgment without first
investigating the circumstances not for
his sake but for the sake of those under
judgment whether they'll be punished or
blessed
amen amen
thank you all the skeet well I guess we
can wrap things up now there are some
questions
but uh I guess just moving forward
especially for non-adventus I know you
mentioned 1844 made 1844 made simple Yes
by Clifford Goldstein but foreign
all right then so friends I know there
are more questions than times
if it's connected all right so we have
some that are connected all right all
right so let me see here
it was an interesting one okay Acts
how would you explain to non-sdas who
think that the scapegoat is Jesus and
that we think the devil is the one
bearing our sin so I guess how do we
identify that the skateboard is not
Jesus all right okay good question good
question from Dr maboshi all right let's
go to Leviticus chapter 16 Leviticus 16.
okay
let's go to verse
19 and verse 20.
all right the Bible says and he shall
sprinkle of the blood upon it with his
fingers
and cleanse it and Hollow it from the
uncleanness of the children of Israel
and when he hath made an end of
atonement excuse me an end of
reconciling the holy place and the
Tabernacle of the congregation the altar
now pause right there the holy Place
refers to the most holy place
that's what the author means by all he
plays there because the holy place is
called the Tabernacle of a congregation
so the Bible says when he has made an
end and reconciling the most holy place
the Tabernacle of the congregation and
the altar which means all atonement for
sin uh is finished
then he takes that goal keep reading
shall bring the live goat uh-huh and
Aaron shall lay both hands hold his
hands upon the head of the live goat
right and confess over him yes all the
iniquities of the children of Israel now
that God is not functioning as a savior
he is bearing the responsibility as the
instigator of sin and you see he has to
pay for what he's instigated that's
what's happening but notice the Bible
says clearly when the priest has
finished atoning for the most holy place
for the holy place or the congregational
the the come get the the
those three when that's done then he
deals with the animal that represents
Satan and that animal is taken away by
the strong man Into the Wilderness never
comes back so the Escape boat does not
the dawn in the sense of Jesus did no
he's just paying for what he's done over
thousands of years that's what that
world represents let me say again
the the most holy place the Tabernacle
of the congregation and the altar they
are taken care of first
and what happens to that boat has
nothing to do with those three that's
where sin is taken care of with respect
to Salvation
what's confession ahead of the goal you
started sin you're the instigator now
you're going to pay for it and putting
it on your head and out into the
Woodworks that's not that has no
solidific value for God's people it is
the sacrifice of Christ that's like
calling Christ Satan that goat
represents Satan the originator an
instigator of sin we must not call Satan
Christ
terrible terrible terrible crime to
confuse his Satan
thank you brother my
man well thank you Elder skeet for your
favor and fire for the word of God
yes yes and for just expounding on this
topic of the investigative judgment and
I wanted to see that it's literally
based
conclusion that we
that to the Sanctuary system
for example the scapegoat we spoke about
represents Satan you know after the
Millennium and after this you know that
thousand years you know everything that
we have learned today has shown us that
this judgment that is taking place is
literally far behalf this is the work of
Christ so that he can be saved and so
that we can have an understanding that
God is just God is just loving yes that
his character indeed is true
so thank you so much for carving out of
your very busy schedule this time with
us and speak on this all important
distinguishing topic of the
investigative judgment it is Central to
our theology Central
that's why the devil attacks it through
former Adventists and uninformed
non-adventus he attacks that Doctrine
more than any other
but he will fail
you will fail go to John chapter eight
and I'll then I'll let you go John 8 or
you let me go John
whether it's verse 4 read verse 43
listen to Jesus and cast your mind on
people who just won't understand God's
word John 8 43. why do ye not understand
my speech
even because you cannot hear my word
they don't have a heart to hear and to
obey now who can make something simpler
than Jesus and they refuse to listen so
Christ in all
you know that's one of the places where
I think Christ was frustrated why do ye
not understand my speech who can make it
simpler there are some people no matter
what you say they don't want to obey
they don't want to believe because their
lives will have to change
and I hope no one listening to us fits
that description because it's sad
well brothers and sisters may we make
our lives right with goddess Elder skeet
said in answers to that question Jasmine
asks what should we be doing now the
children of Israel doing on the day of
atomic they were afflicting theirselves
making sure that they were right with
God and it's not just about our actions
but what do our motives say what about
our thoughts are we aligning our lives
with the standard of judgment the law of
God
things we can meditate on let me say
this also one of the things the church
did on the day of eternal rich and
typically is investigative judgment was
church worship
they came together to worship
we must not allow
modern platforms like this to keep us
away from the church
are you following me one of the features
of the investigative day in the symbolic
form in the Old Testament was
congregational worship around the
sanctuary they came there were four
things that distinguished Behavior
confessing sins fasting no working and
fellowshipping together those four
things must distinguish our behaviors
today Lord we don't work but work must
not become our priority a preparation
for Christ becomes our priority and
despite zoom and saying whatever else we
should make an attempt to get back into
sellership one with the other face to
face and not just lie down at home you
know pajamas and claim to be worshiping
God
amen amen amen thank you all the skeet
and there has just been an expressions
of Love on YouTube and in the chat
sister Angela Buckner says God bless you
Elder skeet
yes may God attend you throughout this
week and I should say all this week you
know while this live was going on uh
well I don't even should I even mention
this all right yeah I'll just leave it
right there but praise God for his truth
praise God for his word
um and there are many others Brother
Joseph sister Beverly registered and I
probably have missed others brother
Israel this has really been blessing
yes and thank you for your prayers on my
behalf always always thank you thank you
always always please give sister skeet
our love and regards I shall do that I'm
flying back home tomorrow I'm in Chicago
right now oh wow playing home tomorrow
uh we'll see I will do that thank you my
dear assistant God bless you and yours
and God bless all those who listen May
Lord bless you I really mean that
sincerely Christ is coming back please
don't allow anything to cause you to be
unprepared when he comes get ready and
the time to be ready is today not
tomorrow today surrender your life to
Christ and then surrender again tomorrow
oh five minutes from now it doesn't take
that long to say father take my life and
guide me altering do they say that
amen amen thank you thank you so much
eldest skeet for that charge Brothers
welcome you're welcome let's align
ourselves with God moment by moment yes
indeed yes yes okay
all right I'll just skeet I'll let you
know God bless you bye bye well say a
prayer before I go assistant Alicia say
a prayer before I go yes yes dear Lord
we thank you for your grace and your
mercies and we thank you for access to
truth and a special way father we thank
you for Elder skeet Elder Randy skeet
and the ministry that you have entrusted
to him and his exercise of his willpower
of his entire life for your service you
know he had a church service right
before coming to this live and is so
fervent about this word that time is not
even a factor I pray father that you
will bless him beyond measure I pray
that as he travels to and fro that you
will protect him put a special hedge of
protection around him so that no evil
will come nigh him I pray that you
continue to provide for his needs and
give him strength for the day-to-day
challenges of living in this world I
pray father that even when he's alone
when he's on the plane traveling as he's
moving from this place to that place
that your presence will ever go with him
that he will abide with you and ever
taste and experience Your Glory
I pray father that you will allow him to
ever experience your love your grace and
your truth and that wherever he goes
that brothers and sisters men and women
even people that have not yet come to
know you will see Jesus in him may his
life continue to be a testimony of the
transforming power of God
we thank you for not only him but his
wife as well even as she's at home
continue to protect her continue to keep
her safe even when he is not there I
pray father that even their lifestyle
their home will be a blessing to those
in their community and neighborhood
wherever they go at home at school at
work I pray father that they will be
beacons of light and towers of strength
even shoulders to cry on and lean on for
those that need it as they express the
love of Jesus in practical ways
I asked father that you will bless them
as eldest skeet would say super
abundantly beyond measure overwhelm them
with your goodness may your goodness and
mercy follow them all the days of their
life dear Lord and they may they dwell
in the house of the Lord forever and
ever Lord God we thank you for Elder
skeet we thank you for his ministry his
family all of his loved ones and his
influence may he ever Shine for you we
thank you for hearing and answering this
prayer and Lord restore his strength
and I pray that two Elder skeet will
also take some time to rest and recoup
even as he works tirelessly for you we
thank you for hearing and answering this
prayer in Jesus name amen amen thank you
God bless you my dear friends and God
bless you Dr Denisha
we'll meet again sometime in the future
when God arranges it
amen right okay
thank you so much Elder skeet you're
welcome you're welcome
yes many thanks to all of you that are
here I pray that this uh this session
this this Bible study
um was refreshing and enlightening
eye-opening we can we know who we are
and and share this message with elder
skeet um via Twitter
the first thing that the devil attacked
was Jesus's identity when he was taken
into the Wilderness he said if thou be
the Son of God turn these stones into
bread brothers and sisters do we know
who we are do we know why we are who we
are we are seventh day Adventists and we
believe in the investigative judgment
and I'm sure there are those of you that
are watching online who are not
seven-day Adventists this is who we are
and we believe the Bible and the Bible
only I pray that you too will join us in
this journey of getting to know God as
other skeet said recently knowing god
reveals Who We Are
all right so let us move on now with our
program we're blessed to have Sister
Christian cattle joining us once again
you've seen her on Q and A's with Dr
Walter fight for many of our Sabbath
concerts she has been here and this
afternoon she'll be ministering lift
every voice and sing and I want you to
listen very closely to especially the
last stanza that she sings so please
welcome sister Christian cattle
thank you
size and Sabbath everyone
see that my sister is in here Anisha
happy Savage sister happy Sabbath big
sis all right I'll start off with a
quick prayer
there have any father
continue to guide me to use me in Jesus
name precious name amen
lifts every
voice sensing
[Music]
bunnies
of
Liberty
let our
voice sin rise
highest
in the sky let it ReSound loud after
all in see
sing a song full of the faith that the
present has taught us
seeing a song full of the hope that the
present has brought
us
Jesus God only said home from salvation
come
let us march on till Victory is one
God of our weary
peace God of our silent tears thou who
has brought us
into
thy might let us into
thy life keep us forever in the path so
we pray
lest our feet stray from the places Our
God where we met thee last our hearts
trunk With the Wind of the world we
forget
thee
shadowed beneath thy hands may we
forever
[Music]
true to our
native land amen
amen amen thank you so much sister
Christian cattle for ministering that
selection we know it's Black History
Month this is the last Sabbath of Black
History Month
um but I'm especially drawn to that last
stanza God of our weary years God of our
silent tears thou who has by thy might
let us into the light keep us forever in
the path we pray Jesus says in John 14 6
I am the way the truth and the life
we don't want to be drunk with the wine
of the world we already know that from
Revelation chapter 14 verses 6 through
12 Our Hope and our foundation is in
Jesus Christ and we build on that Solid
Rock
right now Jesus is interceding on our
behalfs our lives are coming through the
record
our motives our thoughts
they are being investigated
but if we align ourselves with the law
of God we know we can only do that
through Jesus Christ only through the in
working of the Holy Spirit can we be one
with God
but when we align ourselves and we make
that decision to say yes Lord I Choose
You Yes Lord I choose to hearken unto
your voice
Jesus covers Us and where we cannot make
it he makes up
are counted Worthy so that God can be
the justifier of those that believe in
him even his son Jesus Christ the
judgment is in our favor if we believe
and live according to the word of God
so that's our charge today
so I am now going to turn it over to
brother Avery Jones a budding young
vivacious Pastor in the making to give
us our closing prayer
for the Avery
I'd be Sabbath happy Sabbath
um I was truly blessed I hope you all
were blessed um I learned a lot about
the investigative judgment um I'd like
to thank the Nisha for allowing me to be
a part of this program
they follow God
I'd like to thank you again for life
thank you for
bringing Randy's Key here to teach us
about the investigative judgment I'd
like to thank you for this platform
their father that is acting as a city
set on a hill to teach the world about
the knowledge knowledge of Jesus Christ
Our Father
I like to be reminded of James 2 verses
12 which says so speaky and so do
like you're going to be judged by the
law of Liberty to father and I like to
ask that this would resign resonate with
our hearts as we carry on with our
day-to-day lives as seven a event is
outside of the Saturn
that through our lives
through our behaviors that we may Point
others to Christ their father
the father remind us that we must
speak to you every day and give the life
to you every day that when investigative
judgment comes that we will be on the
right side of their father covered in
Jesus Christ their father
this ask in your name and in the name of
Jesus Christ amen amen
amen and amen thank you so much everyone
that has participated well many thanks
to God for what he has done the
opportunity to delve into his word is
one that we ought not to take for
granted and we thank God that he allowed
everything to run smoothly I thank God
as well for Elvis keeps taking the time
to be here with us sister Jasmine Bowen
thank you for coming home quickly so
that you can be here to ask the
questions with me many blessings to you
and even in your career as a nurse
we thank God as well for Sister
Christian cattle and even her dad who's
here you guys are not able to see I
don't know if you guys want to come on
the line but thank God for if you can
stoop down but the culture is a big
supporter and there's his daughter
Sister Christian thank you for taking
the time to come down in fact Sister
Christian came from upstate New York uh
so we thank God that she came here to
minister
um and many thanks to you brother Avery
Jones he's so excited about the word of
God he said Tanisha I want to do
something something simple though maybe
a Bible reading maybe a prayer and he is
here so we thank God for your ministry
and your desire and willingness to serve
brother Avery many thanks as well to my
mom whom I know has been praying
earnestly and fervently for this program
that many will get to know who our
savior is and the work that is going on
right now so those of you on YouTube on
Facebook Twitter twitch and on Zoom
thank you for your presence
we thank God that you have a desire for
truth a desire to hear truth we know
that is something that is implanted by
the Holy Spirit I thank you all for your
presence and even for taking the time to
share this message with someone else
this is present truth present truth
tells us what Jesus is doing right now
and right now he is interceding on our
behalfs right now our names are coming
up in the judgment
so thank you for being here and I hope
that someone at least one or two persons
will hear this word and accept Jesus
Christ so until then until the return of
Our Lord may we keep faithful may we
keep faithful to our Lord and savior all
right then everyone thank you for your
time and may God bless you super
abundantly
yes
all right
thank you all for joining I'm not sure
if the life has stopped
but
let me
ah yes brother hope diamore
thank you for joining
and we in fact let's just take some time
to pray for you right now
um
yeah let's pray dear Lord we thank you
so much for allowing us to be here and
allowing
um brother hope to join this Zoom call
um you know he indeed reached out to me
and let me know that he was not well but
father I pray in the name of Jesus that
you will touch his body
be with his liver be with all of the
blood flowing through his blood vessels
and I pray that you would Purge it of
every parasite
from that malaria everything that is
afflicting his body right now I pray
that you'd remove it in the name of
Jesus father we believe your word we
take you at your word father just just
speak a word of healing to his life
remove the fevers remove the night
sweats remove every ill that is
afflicting his body and I pray that you
give him Deliverance physically
emotionally mentally spiritually dear
Lord I pray that this will even be a
testimony not only for him but for even
those in his community that will say
wait a second wasn't he just ill but now
he has made whole that will be a
testimony of your power so father I'm
asking that you forgive me of my sins
and please hear this humble prayer heal
your son heal your son in Jesus name we
pray amen
yeah hang up amen
all right thank you again everyone for
joining I'm going to try to
uh
uh end the stream I'm not sure if it is
it is stopped